Oly ET cameras were invited along with
their amazing good works mission but as
Brooke Anderson found out sometimes
meeting the real buzz lightyear could be
a buzzkill sometimes especially the
younger boys especially like Buzz
Lightyear and they see me and it's like
why is this ugly man talking like
bustling and it kind of makes them angry
so I'm likely to get a syringe thrown I
don't know that they actually put in the
UGL Y word there was nothing ug ly about
this kid patients and their families
that Orlando's Advent health children's
hospital getting showered with l.o.v.e
from Tom and Tim the guys delivered a
ton of goodies books games autographed
toys
and posed for some selfies it's all a
part of the Disney team of heroes
initiative which supplies gifts to over
445 children's hospitals across the
country why is this so special and so
important for you guys to be here today
doing this see the fact we're asked is
amazing that they even trust that we
should do this let's bring the
playground to them for almost 25 years
the Toy Story franchise has been the
playground for woody and buzzes dynamic
friendship as well as Tom and Tim's and
reading the final pages of this script
proofed emotional for the longtime
friends he said we still friends because
he didn't stand us it's a cartoon but I
said you should be prepared which of
these last four pages beautifully
written is sounding like a shirring your
best buddy that you got a friend tonight
and look before we get all sentimental
this isn't the end tim has already said
he is down to do five and Beyond and he
did not sue us
he didn't sue us
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]